parler du ghana louis keumayou
journaliste président du code de
l'information africaine bonjour louis
keumayou merci de répondre à nos
questions les deux candidats à la
présidentielle avait signé il ya pas si
longtemps un pacte de paix entente
cordiale donc rompue à l'annoncé des
résultats
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer cela
s'est fait par le fait que la démocratie
n'est jamais un produit parfait il
arrive toujours que pas par moments et
des relents de contestation qui monte et
que ces relents aille jusqu'à
déstabiliser le pays
sur ces bases démocratiques mais je
pense que c'est un épisode qui va pas
durer longtemps
les ghanéens retrouveront ce sens à la
fois de la courtoisie du respect des
institutions qui la caractérise depuis
plusieurs années et qui fait que le gars
n'est toujours du un exemple de
démocratie pour la plupart des pays
africains à la fois au sein de la cedeao
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest
mais dans l'afrique de façon plus
générale il ya eu cinq morts depuis
lundi mais qu'également au moins 17
blessés à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre prochainement dans les rues
au ghana est ce qu'on peut voir une
flambée des violences
je pense que les résultats politiques
ont toujours les la vie politique des
pays africains est rythmée par
l'élection présidentielle généralement
sur les résultats des législatifs
il n'ya pas toujours de contestation a
lancé elles sont vraiment très minime
mais les moments qui sont des moments de
crise voire des moments confligène ce
sont ceux de la proclamation de
l'élection présidentielle et
malheureusement le ghana est en train de
retomber dans ce travers de la
contestation
pour le moment ça reste une contestation
non violentes même si des personnes sont
décédées ce sont des choses qui
échappent souvent dans le feu de
l'action à au contrôle des personnes qui
ont lancé le mouvement
mais je crois que dans moins de cinq
jours les choses dieu prend être revenu
dans l'ordre
parce que l'opposition a quand même
remporté la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et a les moyens aujourd'hui
d'exercer un contre-pouvoir pour pour
éviter que le pouvoir absolu soit entre
les mains d'hommes président o
potins et qu'ils ne soient pas
contestées par par l'assemblée nationale
justement c'est très serré il a été
réélu
nana akufo addo avec 51 points 59 % des
voix une victoire donc acquise de peu à
ce que c'est à cause de ça que le
résultat est contesté
ou bien ce que c'est pour des raisons
purement politiques
je pense que ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis n'est pas ne laisse pas
indifférent les ghanéens faut pas
oublier que le modèle politique du ghana
c'est celui des etats unis
c'est une élection présidentielle pour
un mandat de quatre ans avec un
vice-président élu sur le même ticket
que le président est donc quand on voit
la manière dont les élections le
résultat des élections aux états unis
est contesté par le président sortant en
l'occurrence donald trump
il n'est pas étonnant que l'opposition
gallienne également en prennent de la
graine et se mettre dans la roue de du
président club mais je crois que tout
cela relève d'un échec qui n'est pas
assumée par les par l'opposition mais
qui le sera dans les prochaines heures
puisque la force du ghana c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas uniquement de prises de
position idéologique
c'est également une façon de gérer le
pouvoir et du jeu la vie politique à
travers des institutions qui sont là
pour le coup très solide dans ce pays
d'afrique de l'ouest
un mot sur les à l'international les
observateurs internationaux que distille
exactement et la communauté
internationale ce qu'elle va reconnaître
un âne akufo addo comme comme le
président est ce qu'on attendait des
déclarations les fera quoi selon vous
les déclarations pour boro ce qui est
compliqué simplement c'est au niveau
sous régional
c'est que le ghana aujourd'hui préside
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest et ses dogmes de la
foi d'eau qui en est le président il ne
peut pas envoyer un message de
félicitations mais après c'est au niveau
de l'union africaine et de ses pairs
pris individuellement dans chacun des
pays en côte d'ivoire au togo au burkina
faso pour les voisins les plus humides
à tulle en verrons probablement leur ca
leurs félicitations mais pousse là de
mon point de vue ne se passera qu'après
que le contentieux électoral est été
apurés auprès des institutions
compétentes au ghana donc pour l'instant
ce sont des résultats provisoires ils
sont contestés par toute provisoire mail
une fois que les différentes
institutions de validation seront
passées je pense que les félicitations
arriveront à ce que ce ne sont pas les
élections aujourd'hui qui sont les moins
bien organisés du continent on a vu des
pays sur le continent africain qui
souffrait de conflit et ne pouvait pas
gérer l'ensemble de leurs territoires
organiser des élections en mettant en
marge une partie du territoire une
partie de la population des lecteurs
sans que cela soit constatée contestées
dans le cas du ghana s'est véritablement
sonné après à chaud dans la proclamation
des résultats provisoires et que tous ne
reconnaissent pas leur défaite mais je
n'ai aucun doute que dans les prochaines
heures voire dans les prochains jours
ces résultat soit accepté par l'ensemble
de la classe politique
merci louis keumayou d'abord a répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste est le président du club de
l'information africaine